hmm you seem to have a 40 lane fee on a
book called mysteries of the female
orgasm pawnee's library department is
the most diabolical ruthless bunch of
bureaucrats i've ever seen they're like
a biker gang
but instead of shotguns and crystal meth
they use
political savvy and shushing
ron
jack cooper from the controller's office
gotta got a second sure what can i do
you for frankly this is a little awkward
we received this letter from a
collection agency about an outstanding
debt from the pawnee public library it
appears you have an overdue book or do i
it's not the size of the boat embracing
life with a micro penis
tammy leslie this guy's here
hi can i help you i'm kelly larson i
read online about your time capsule and
i'm here to make a suggestion oh i'm
sorry we're not taking suggestions
twilight books
it's a beautifully told saga vampires
werewolves and romance ah you are the
person that's been emailing me about
twilight i thought you would be younger
and a girl well i'm not i'm older than a
boy but i feel very strongly that these
should be included can i tell you why
sure kelly have a seat awesome plead
your case thanks
okay christmas eve 1973. author
stephanie meyer nae morgan was born in
hartford connecticut oh you're going all
the way back to her birth okay you look
sad you look like a weird goon who's
obsessed with a kid's book it's a girl
isn't it
i can tell
it's the look that mike had on his face
when bella turned him down for the dance
oh yeah is it what look did your mom
have on her face when she realized her
son was a complete failure okay i'll be
quiet
but i do know something about heartbreak
and you know who else does
kenneth babyface edmonds no a little
lady named twilight author stephanie
meyer
trust me
you should listen to him those books are
good
oh i love any book about vampires
werewolves monsters zombies sorcerers
beasties or time traveling romances and
if i had an hour alone with robert
pattinson he would forget all about
skinny legs mcgee i tell you that much
okay buddy time is up give us the keys
they're hidden somewhere very far away
then we're gonna have to cut you loose
why i'm not doing anything wrong yes you
are you're trespassing well the fact
remains this is perfectly legal no it's
not you're trespassing look i i really
don't want to cause any trouble but i am
not gonna leave until you put twilight
in the time capsule this muscle-headed
stormtrooper doesn't scare me
go ahead artie
please no no no no no no get away with
me
i'm very scared of you
all right all right stop
if he wants to stay in there i'll let
him stay in there in two hours he's
gonna be so hungry and freaked out he's
gonna be begging me to
he brought a pillow hey let's say i'm
making some sleepy time tea you want any
all you need to do is guide it into
place
what i get from that is when parenting
sometimes a subtle hand is more
effective than a strong one
this is already so much more helpful
than the last book in parenting i read
rad dads by apollo anton ono and sean
white
[Music]
ron why did you throw that wood away
it's unstable it's no good i just don't
understand the throwing away the wood
metaphor
what's the lesson oh i know
it's potty training
that trash can is the toilet and the
wood was the pieces chris i'm not
teaching you anything we're just
building a crib no i know you're not
consciously teaching me anything i'm
just trying to siphon off some of your
calm centered wisdom through metaphors
metaphors i hate metaphors that's why my
favorite book is moby dick
no frou-frou symbolism just a good
simple tale about a man who hates an
animal does the white whale actually
symbolize the unknowability and
meaninglessness of human existence
yeah no it's just a fish
i hate it here this place is evil i
think these are the only two films that
say sweetums on the label yeah well
let's take them both we might find
something interesting here just stick
them under my shirt just walk out they
have sensors just check them out it's
free
hi marcy leslie
are they finally teaching you parks
people how to read
oh i guess not it's a movie you're
pretty cocky for someone whose job is
obsolete because of the internet
[Laughter]
let's see
hmm you seem to have a 40 late fee on a
book called mysteries of the female
orgasm no i don't yeah you do
and grab the movie go go go go
punk book jockey
joan on behalf of the entire city
congratulations i do want to apologize
for not being able to accommodate some
of your requests for example we couldn't
get a bottle of chateau marmont because
it's a hotel in los angeles not a wine
well did you at least get buddy holly to
sing no because he's been famously dead
for 60 years what hi joan hi my name is
april and i'm your biggest fan and i
pretty much hate everyone will you sign
your ninth memoir for me well it would
be my pleasure
it's over tammy tell you what it's been
long enough
what do you say we
consummate our relationship
tonight
huh
let's
do it
and the last card is played what are you
doing shh this is a library you see
what's happening here
look we need to talk
ron no
the planning department reprioritization
document calm down i haven't signed it
yet yeah where you're going to because
tammy wants you to and you do everything
that she wants she made some really good
points about libraries are you even
listening to yourself you're defending
the library now ron the library of all
the horrifying miserable things in the
world some people like libraries i can't
even believe what i'm hearing some
people like libraries ron tammy what are
you doing here
oh i just have a little something i need
to get drilled
can i speak with you for a moment
everything's fine we're just gonna chat
shouldn't you be at the library forcing
people to borrow books tom i have pawnee
today in an hour was my book selected
for jones book club joan calamezzo as a
book club
joan calamezzo started a book club four
years ago and now she is the literary
taste maker in the town the time
traveler's optometrist by pawnee's own
penelope foster a heartwarming story
about a caveman eye doctor who travels
to present-day cincinnati and can see
everything but love
unreadable
then jones slaps her sticker on it best
seller four years in a row
you